if they were betting odds like if we did
a poll why do you think andrew tate was
banned from all the social media
platforms and it was
misogyny right you know covet stuff
against the governments against system
if you were a betting man
where would you kind of place the odds
oh i already know everybody already
knows i was banned because i talk
against
against the matrix you know the system
in general the system in general yeah i
mean
someone compared me to
socrates which is a compliment but he
was vilified he ended up poisoning
himself in athens and the charge against
him
was
corrupting the youth if you read about
his poisoning and his arrest they said
he was corrupting the youth but he
wasn't corrupting them he was inspiring
them to challenge authorities inspiring
them to think for themselves when they
were told something instead of blindly
complying he said look analyze who these
people are who are telling you to do x
and i even had a tweet i put out
on my i mean i've been banned on twitter
forever so i've because i've been
through 20 twitter bands i come back as
undercover whatever but i i've been
saying for all i said often i said if
you have a str if you have a point of
view that you are very strong
in your adherence to if you truly
believe something you need to sit and
analyze whether it's your own personal
experience that makes you believe
something or if something someone else
or something else has convinced you of
this and if they have you need to then
once again analyze that point of view
and analyze who this who these people
are and what they want from you do they
truly want the best of you if the news
convinces you of something to the point
where you're going to argue with your
only own family members at dinner table
does the news really care about you more
than your family this is a genuine
question you need to analyze every
belief you hold where it came from
and then analyze what their intentions
are
and if you start to do that you look at
something like covid for example it's an
easy one you look all the [ __ ] they
were saying and you sit here and go wait
wait these people don't care about me
if i had diabetes or insulin i needed
insulin or if i had cancer or i if i got
a car crash anything they'd be hitting
me with
medical bills i could never possibly
afford they'd let me die
but they are insisting i take this shot
for free on repeat this doesn't make
sense
and when you and when you encourage
people to think for themselves
especially the youth that's what
socrates got accused of he's corrupting
the youth
and and to be honest with you a huge
portion of my fan base were 18 to 23 24
year old males
when you have the youth the masculine
youth of the world thinking for
themselves that's pretty scary to
authority because it's the masculine
youth of the world that is one the
revolutionaries and two also that's the
backbone of the slave force if you need
people to go die in a ditch in
afghanistan you need them you need
people to work [ __ ] jobs in a coal
mine with no health care you need them
if you need people to blindly comply to
[ __ ] you need them more than anybody
more than you need the feminists and the
[ __ ]
the liberals you need the real men to go
out there and comply with the [ __ ]
to live a shitty existence to purport
and prop up a system the warrior the
warrior class right and if enough of
these men stand in one place and say
this is enough that's when a revolution
happens so this is the most dangerous
group of the demographic that the matrix
and the people are trying to control and
they have to have a narrative over and
that's why they're trying to weaken them
in every regard and when i'm sitting
there saying don't listen to the
[ __ ] become physically strong think
for yourself prioritize your brotherhood
above what the [ __ ] matrix is telling
you do not blindly comply or do you know
resist the slave mind all these things
i'm saying they just sat there one day
and said wait the most popular person on
the planet is saying don't listen to our
[ __ ]
delete
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to watch the entire podcast click over
here and if you want to be connected
with experts influencers such as
kiyosaki tate connolly parliamentary
myself and others download the app
minect where you get a chance to connect
with these folks by the minute you get
to buy the minute or have face times
with them 15 minutes ask them any
questions you may want to have download
the app connect and start connecting
with influencers and experts today
[Music]